ah hey you please stop bothering like
him so
Arthur I have some bad news for you this
is the last time we'll be meeting you
don't listen dear you just asked the
same questions every week how's your job
are you having any negative thoughts all
I have are negative thoughts
finally everyone thinks they can do my
job
check out this guy when I was a little
boy and told people I was gonna be a
comedian everyone laughed at me well no
one's laughing now you can say that
again
[Music]
so Hospital isn't it
for my whole life
I didn't know if I even really existed
[Music]
but I do
people are starting to notice
I think this is funny
there's a joke to you
very one small thing yeah when you bring
me out can you introduce me as Joker
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got a brand new
Joker trailer to break down the movies
coming out next month so we only have to
wait a couple more weeks to actually
watch it and it's getting crazy
Awards consideration seriously everybody
has been 180 on this film the last
couple of trailers that we've got
they've been taking it to a bunch of
prestige film festivals so there's a
bunch of Easter eggs in this let's break
it down we'll do a giveaway for movie
tickets all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber and leave your best Joker
theory on the video the trailer is
pretty open about the movie's themes
positioning the Joker as the protagonist
in Thomas Wayne as his self ascribed
antagonist even though there are a lot
of other people that you could point to
during the trailer in his life to treat
him really bad that you could also call
antagonist there was a bunch of footage
in the last trailer though where he
actually goes to Wayne Manor at the
fence and interacts with a young boy
that seems like it's going to be Bruce
Wayne probably one of the biggest Batman
Easter eggs you may have noticed is when
all the criminals are wearing the clown
mask going crazy in the streets one of
them runs through the front of this
theater you notice the poster for
Excalibur on the wall here it's the same
Excalibur poster that was on the wall of
Zack Snyder's Batman V Superman
during the origin sequence where his
parents died in Crime Alley and if it
wasn't clear during the movie Thomas
Wayne is running for mayor and based on
the clothes people are wearing in the
level of Technology it seems like this
is happening somewhere between the 70s
and the 80s in Gotham but they really
bent over backwards in this trailer to
make you sympathize with his character
there had been other stories that
they've told about the Joker's life
before he became the Joker like on
Batman the Animated Series there was
that episode called make him laugh the
deals with Joker's backstory and how he
was an aspiring stand-up comedian that
nobody thought was funny then by the end
of the episode he's back on stage
terrorizing everyone who's laughing now
so you sort of see a similar descent in
this where he realizes that nobody's
listening to him is this big commentary
about the way the people in Gotham treat
mental illness not giving him the
consideration that he needs the way they
treat the underclass as well also
commentary on the way Gotham City treats
the rich people versus the poor people
that's what that big modern times Easter
Egg is like they go to that big opera
house where modern times is screening
that's the Charlie Chaplin movie that
was all about the plight of the
working class during the Depression so
as long as you understand that they're
trying to position Joker as the hero of
this movie at least the hero in his mind
that it makes a little bit more sense
new footage of him on the bus trying to
get a laugh out of this little kid
having a little bit of fun the mom not
wanting to have anything to do with him
sorry sorry for bothering you we got to
talk about his Joker left he did say
that it took a long time to actually
find that he said I just tried a whole
bunch of different things and
workshopped it so you just have to
picture Joaquin Phoenix in his free time
while they were making this movie
walking around at his house just trying
out different crazy crazy laughs it was
the same thing for Mark Hamill coming up
with his iconic Joker lab so I see Mark
Hamill's is still probably my favorite
Joker lap the one that Joaquin Phoenix
is doing is a little bit different but
it does feel very similar to Mark
Hamill's Joker laughs they do a little
better job of cutting him getting his
ass beat on the street just by common
criminal kids just trying to terrorize
him while he's talking to his therapist
you don't listen to me you just tell me
the exact same thing every time I come
in here you have no idea what's going on
with me all of my thoughts are terrible
thoughts there isn't quite as much
footage of his home life but he's been
taking care of his mother who's played
by Francis Conroy there was a whole
bunch of footage of her in the last
trailer but you see him in the hospital
watching himself on Robert De Niro's
television show and I love that king of
comedy turn obviously a lot of what's
going on with the Robert De Niro part of
the movie is very king of comedy with
Robert De Niro playing the Jerry Lewis
role from that movie as the host of that
comedy show completely dissing the
Joker's character which is basically the
same thing that happened during King of
Comedy
when Robert De Niro's character who was
kind of the Joker of that movie tried to
make it big on his show the difference
with the Joker movie in adapting that
kind of story is that it tries to get
you to sympathize with him way more than
the King of Comedy tries to get you to
sympathize with Robert De Niro's version
of that Joker type character there's a
whole bunch of brand-new footage of them
in this big subway sequence where you
see the cops chasing him you see the
clown masks down here this is all after
he's enacted his grand plan to get
people to quote/unquote realize what's
going on it's not totally clear whether
or not he goes on Robert De Niro's
television show as the Joker earlier in
the film then that's what inspires all
these other people to start wearing
Joker masks in committing all these
crimes because all the scenes of this
crazy chaos and the cops trying to chase
him down seems like it's happening a
little bit later in the film there's a
whole bunch of new footage of as Ozzy
beats with him during the trailer you'll
remember her from Deadpool - she just
plays his girlfriend during this someone
who sympathizes with him someone who
listens to him it'll be interesting to
see how she takes all this joker stuff
once she realizes what he's doing as
much as they want you to view him as the
protagonist of this movie like there's
some victory that he's trying to achieve
and we the audience are supposed to
cheer him on and identify with him as he
tries to achieve that goal I will be
really blown away if they end this movie
with him achieving some big victory in
it feeling really amazing but it does
feel like they would try to do something
like that in the Joker movie like if
Christopher no one made the Dark Knight
from Joker's perspective and you were
meant to cheer him on as he's killing
all these people causing all this chaos
some men just want to watch the world
burn can't imagine that paint tastes
very good
but some of this is just repeated
footage from the last trailer of him
walking to his performance on Robert De
Niro's television show the comedy club
where he's performing at the X you see
footage of that when Robert De Niro's
burning him earlier like this guy is
really not funny in the movie the comedy
club is managed by character played by
Marc Maron so look out for his cameo
during this I'm sure there'll be a
couple other minor cameos that you might
recognize Bryan Tyree Henry from
spider-man into the spider verse and now
the Eternals also has a cameo during
this - so a little bit of Sony Marvel
and DC crossover if you don't recognize
Bryan tyree Henry he played Miles
Morales his father during spider-man
into the spider burst he plays what
looks like one of the security guards or
the attendance at this mental
institution where Joker is going to see
his therapist recently he was announced
in the Eternals movie for Marvel so
we'll see him in a couple years during
that the crazy arc of this as you see
him sort of cheering in the middle of
this crowd while the chaos is going on
around them people holding up those
since we're all clowns wearing those
mess looks like him just enjoying the
fruits of his public appearances as that
Joker character like he goes on Robert
De Niro's television show inspires all
these people to rise up wearing these
clown masks then walks around without
his makeup on like a normal person so
people won't recognize them
just enjoying the fruits of all this how
crazy is it though the Thomas Wayne just
clocks
him right in the face they really want
you to think that he's the villain of
this movie I don't know exactly how that
arc is gonna pan out but for a little
while Alec Baldwin was gonna be Thomas
Wayne in the movie before he dropped out
then I love the way they end the trailer
with that Frank Sinatra send in the
clown song with the epic montage of
things going completely chaotic him
celebrating his rise to prominence and
fame as this Joker persona trying to
make all the kids in the cancer ward
laugh as his Joker persona while
everyone is running around outside in
the streets as he's curb stomping
someone behind this business and then
just quietly sort of walking away from
the scene of this crime in the subway
anytime I hear that send in the clown
song all I can think about is the Krusty
the Klown special episode of The
Simpsons it was his big comeback special
where Bette Midler and all those famous
stars came to help bring him back into
prominence but let me know in the
comments what your favorite moment from
the trailer was and I know there's still
a lot of questions about where this fits
in the larger DC continuity this film is
not meant to be connected to Justice
League or any of those bigger DC films
like Aquaman Wonder Woman any of the
Batman movies like they're getting ready
to shoot that new Batman movie with
Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves that's
not gonna have anything to do with this
continuity that'll be completely
separate take the way they're talking
about this film is that it's sort of
part of this new idea within DC called
DC black label they have a new comic
book label called DC black which is
basically becomes their new version of
vertigo stories that are more mature
written more for adults as opposed to
the regular DC titles which are meant to
be a little bit broader for younger
audiences and if you didn't know this
film is rated R so we're getting a
rated-r Joker film I'm hoping Marvel
does a similar thing with all the
Deadpool stuff is coming over from the
Fox Marvel deal because most of those
films will be pg-13 Deadpool is one of
the few exceptions there's still a
couple titles they could release
there'll be a little more mature that
they might use Fox to release because
Disney does not put their name on
anything that is rated R if they want to
release a rated R movie they'll usually
release it through some other studio
we'll probably get a birds-of-prey
trailer when this comes out in October
so I will do videos for that too they'll
be trailers for that through the end of
the year because that movies coming out
at the beginning of February there's
been a lot of good rumblings about that
movie so we'll talk about that when they
that first trailer but leave all your
video requests in the comments below
congratulations shinobi you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here to learn what's
going on with a spider-man character and
Marvel and Sony and click here for that
big Marvel phase 4 teaser from this past
weekend thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]